a day after gang members looted stores
and terrified people in kito's historic
Center the streets usually brimming with
locals and tourists were desolate most
stores were closed as were schools and
public offices the area close to the
presidential Palace cordoned off with
soldiers on
patrol Alex Lozada who kept his stall
closed says he showed up to protect his
belongings yesterday was terrifying
people running desperately up and down
and around 3: in the afternoon we had to
close it's very dangerous we are all
afraid we'll be robbed or worse a
sentiment of Anguish and worry that
others who ventured out
shared we can't go to work in this
situation children can't go to school
our country is in pieces we need the
president to solve this because it's
gone
berserk the president Danielle NOOA who
declared the State of Emergency on
Monday and ordered that criminal gangs
be neutralized on Tuesday met with
diplomats and international
organizations saying the violence was a
reaction to his plans of building new
high security prisons he promised not to
back down and announced he would begin
to deport 1500 foreign prisoners mostly
Colombians to cut the number of
inmates we're living in a state of war
against terrorism these aren't organized
crime groups they're terrorists
some of whom Finance themselves with
drug trafficking and some others with
people smuggling in organs as well as
Weapons most equadorian are still trying
to make sense of what has been an
unprecedented day of simultaneous
violence in many cities tension remains
palpable streets are empty even at rush
hour as Kito and Ecuador prepare for
another night of curf and the crisis is
far from over 139 prison guards and
employees are still being held hostage
by inmates in five jails and there were
still incidents and clashes in various
parts of the country as the armed forces
operation continues this wave of
violence was triggered by The
Disappearance of a convicted criminal
the government hop to transfer but it's
only the latest in a country
increasingly in the grips of ever more
violent and defiant gangs Alexandra ATI
Al
jazero make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz